creme brulee easily falls into my top
three all-time favorite desserts it's
super simple it only takes five minutes
to prepare it and always impresses
anyone who tries it so I had to make it
again
[Music]
you want to begin by scooping out your
vanilla pod and then heating it up with
heavy cream and sugar until 120 degrees
Fahrenheit now slowly mixing the heated
cream with the egg yolk this step is
super critical because if you add the
cream too fast or if the cream is too
hot then you're gonna get scrambled eggs
[Music]
now divide the mixture equally into your
ramekins fill your deep tray halfway
with hot water and bake for 30 to 40
minutes in an oven preheated to 325
degrees Fahrenheit
[Music]